that's the that's that's statecraft
right that's how you balance and you're
you're hitting the right issues of
course you have to balance and anything
the impact of making a statement on
something vice not making it what would
that will do for our bilateral
relationship what it will do to the
indigenous opportunities that are
happening on the ground that are growing
organically you highlight something if
you highlight it it has an American
stamp and do we really want to do that
and so you're doing that all the Alton
all day every day with a wide variety of
different things so that is part of what
we do with this I mean that's just part
of our natural process as as as people
who work in a really non non organized
world where the lines are not as clear
as they they need to need to be we have
these conversations all the time and and
your answer I mean how do you make that
decision you do what you do in life you
weigh things out and you think about the
short term implications and you think
about the long-term implications